that's a great question you know most
documentaries at least when I were
growing up were sort of like castor oil
they were good for you but hardly good
tasting they were just telling you what
you should know they were the expression
of an already arrived at n-not a process
of discovery I don't pick subjects
because I know about them I pick
subjects because I want to know about
them so my films are not me telling you
what you should know but saying hey
guess what I learned there's a huge big
difference there's there's a subtle
ingredient of enthusiasm that is a part
of that an excitement of the new story
that which is not known a Harry Truman
once said the only thing that's really
new is the history you don't know and
for me each of the subjects is something
I want to delve into its like the
mysteriousness of diving into the deep
end and not knowing precisely how deep
it is and then coming back to report
that that's what we've tried to do with
each film and rather than be this sort
of dull didactic expression of a set of
facts and dates and events you should
know about it is rather an emotional
archaeology that is the glue I hope that
cements all of those dry dates and facts
and events together into something
higher in which the whole is indeed
greater than the sum of the parts and
it's that again calculus that I am so
interested in so every project is a
learning curve every project is about
that excitement of something new that
the little town of Winchester Virginia
changed hands 72 times during the Civil
War we don't think of America as a place
where armies would capture and recapture
that's Europe but that happened in
Winchester Virginia that the state of
Missouri said I think it was 37
regiments to the Battle of expert 21 for
the north and 16 for the south to show
you how the country was torn on the bias
that Jack Johnson who many people think
is just this big brute of a man that
the liberal helpers to get him through
his life own has three patents with the
United States Patent Office because of
the tools that he designed to adjust the
fast cars he liked to drive that he was
a great writer I mean everything comes
with a blizzard a flurry of new things
that you learn and that's the great
excitement that's why you do it that's
where you get up in the morning
you know people ask me that all the time
I don't think my life is worth it i'm a
medium that is to say I you know this is
the 19th century I'd be the guy holding
the seance you know that's in essence
what I'm doing I'm going back into the
past and I'm trying to interpret all of
this random stuff into something that
may make sense for me and I hope other
people because we shares some things in
common I trust I hope but my own life
doesn't seem that important there are
people who always want to make it so
just as the life of painters seemed
interesting to us or architects or other
artists I don't feel so that way I mean
in fact the most important thing to me
in my life is not my filmmaking anyway
it's I have three daughters who range in
age from 27 right now 24 years old and
I'm much more concerned with that
co-production of being a father than
then I am with the films and that's
something entirely different and
obviously private